Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today, I'm going to explain a sci-fi thriller
film called “Level 16.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie starts in an all-girls hostel.
Vivien and Sophia are best friends.
They talk about being adopted one day, suggesting
that the girls are all orphans.
The hostel seems to have very strict rules.
At night, when the blue lights turn on, all
of them go to sleep in their respective beds
without any question.
In the morning, when the alarm goes off, they
all line up in front of the basin...with their
respective jar of face cream and towel to
“clean” themselves.
They have to wash their face in front of a
camera.
Even a little bit of sloppiness can put the
girls in big trouble.
That day, when it’s Vivien’s turn to wash
her face, Sophia drops her face cream.
Sophia has bad eyesight so she has trouble
finding the cream.
Vivien runs to help her, so is a little late
for her turn.
The alarms go off.
Two guards drag Vivien away as she begs them
that she is clean.
Sophia and the other girls silently face the
wall.
The building they live in is an isolated,
artificially lit, and windowless boarding school.
The girls living there have never seen daylight.
They have been in the establishment since
they were babies, starting from level zero.
As they grow older, they move up to higher
floors and higher levels.
The highest level is level sixteen.
When the girls are in level sixteen, they
are eligible to be adopted.
Throughout their lives, they have been taught
to be 'clean' and proper.
They are schooled in health, home skills,
and etiquette.
They are taught that curiosity and anger are
vices that make them less of a girl.
However, they are never taught to read and
write.
Cut to a few years later.
Vivien and Sophia reunite at level sixteen.
But Vivien hates Sophia for being the reason
she was punished back in level ten.
Vivien has now become a “top girl” who
follows the rules of the academy without any questions.
The girls are happy to be at the last level.
On their first day in level sixteen, they
pick a bed for themselves; then take the vitamins
one by one.
Then, they go to eat and move on with their
routined life.
That day, Sophia pulls Vivien aside in the
bathroom to tell her something, but Vivien
dismisses her.
Miss Brixil is their supervisor.
That day, during their assembly, she comes
in with good news.
Brixil has brought a pretty dress for the
girls.
They are beyond delighted.
The dresses have their name embroidered on
them.
The following day, the girls are doing their
chores when Sophia trades her chore with a
girl…to be with Vivien.
She then tells her to just pretend to take
the vitamins and not actually take them.
Before she can tell her the reason, a girl
comes looking for Vivien and takes her away.
Vivien doesn’t trust Sophia, she is sceptical
of the idea but she doesn’t take the vitamins that day.
Later that night, all girls fall asleep except
for Vivien and Sophia.
Sophia then reveals that the vitamins are
actually sleeping pills and that the establishment
has been drugging the girls since level one.
As they talk, they hear footsteps outside
the door.
So, they quickly pretend to be asleep.
Miss Brixil and two guards enter the room.
Brixil chooses two of the girls, Vivien and
Olivia.
The guards pick both of them up and take them
to a room.
Then, Miss Brixil comes in with an old couple.
She tells them about the girls as if they
are goods she is trying to sell.
The couple chooses Olivia.
They want to buy her.
Vivien is shocked to know that they are not
being adopted, but bought by rich families.
Then, she is brought back by the guards to
the room again.
Vivien finally believes everything that Sophia
has said.
Sophia then reveals that she has not taken
those pills since level thirteen; every night,
she stays awake as the girls sleep.
When they got to level sixteen, the guards
started taking girls out every night to show
them to their clients.
When asked what she does at night, Sophia
reveals that she listens to the girls outside.
When these girls go to sleep, the other levels
of girls wake up and do the same routine.
She also tells her about the black hour, where
the hallways go silent and every level of
girls is asleep.
In that hour, a security guard comes into
the room and touches the sleeping girls inappropriately.
As they talk, Brixil comes into the room again.
This time she takes Sophia and one other girl.
After they are gone, Vivien sees the doors
are unlocked.
She is in front of the surveillance camera,
but no alarms ring.
She then tries to open the door outside, but
can’t, so she goes back to the room again.
Soon, Sophia is brought back too.
The following day, the girls are taken to
Dr. Miro’s clinic.
He does his monthly check-up on the girls
and injects them with a chemical... posing
it as a vaccine.
The doctor seems to be friendly.
He tells Vivien of an actress of the same
name, Vivien Leigh, and compliments her smile.
Later, the girls have their movie night.
They watch the same movie that they have been
shown for years.
That night, after the girls fall asleep, Vivien
and Sophia talk about escaping the building.
They know that they need the keycard to open
the doors.
Sophia suggests that they steal it from the
guard that comes in during the black hour;
but Vivien is against the idea.
Instead, she thinks that Dr. Miro can help
them.
The following day she goes to Dr. Miro’s
clinic without him calling her.
She makes up an excuse about wanting to know
what the actress Vivien Leigh looks like.
The doctor lovingly tells her that he will
look into it.
Later that day, the girls are playing some
board games, when one of them gets a seizure
and starts to vomit.
Sophia helps her clean up, while one of the
girls, Ava, suggests they should call the guards.
She assumes that it is because of the vaccine
they were injected with.
That day, as the girls are in their grooming
class, the video of Vivien Leigh plays.
Vivien knows that Dr. Miro put on the show.
At the next Doctor’s appointment, Vivien
thanks Dr Miro.
But as they talk, the doctor gets suspicious
that she has not been taking her vitamins lately.
So he injects her with a drug that will make
her fall asleep.
The whole day, Vivien is hazy.
She slurs on her words while talking to Sophia
and her hair is messy too.
Ava assumes this is because Vivien is lazy
and “unclean”, so she reports it to Ms Brixil.
She gathers the girls and takes Vivien with
her to punish her for being unclean.
She then puts her in a tiny cell and tells
her to reflect on her actions.
Brixil then goes back to her room in the building.
She pours two glasses of alcohol and we get
to know that Dr. Miro and her are actually a couple.
They have a conversation about their boss
who brings the clients.
Suggesting that they, too, work for someone.
Miro reveals that their boss wants them to
“restock” on girls.
Brixil is against the idea, she wants to get
out of this business, but Miro suggests that
they don't have to bring infant girls; they
can get some teenagers and admit them to the establishment.
However, Brixil doesn’t agree.
Cut to that night.
Vivien is still in the cell, while Sophia
makes a rope using the bedsheets.
She plans to attack the security guard who
comes to harass the girls at night.
Just then, he comes in.
When he is about to touch one of the girls,
Sophia chokes him with the rope.
She then rushes outside to free Vivien.
But before she can, the guard attacks her.
He is almost about to kill her when she saves
herself by hitting him with an iron, her nightgown
is splattered with blood.
She then takes his keycard and rushes to Vivien.
However, the alarm starts to ring.
Hence, Sophia runs back to the room.
Vivien cries and tells her to not leave her
this time.
Sometime later, Brixil gets Vivien out and
makes her and the other girls stand in line.
Miro is there too.
They tell the girls that Sophia has betrayed
the establishment and will be punished accordingly.
Then they ask if the girls have the card that
Sophia took.
No one speaks.
Turns out that Sophia had hidden the card
before she was caught.
Dr. Miro is furious.
He threatens the girls that he will take each
one of them for a punishment one by one...until
they find the card.
He then asks the guards to take Rita for the
punishment.
She begs that she hasn’t done anything wrong,
but the guards take her away.
Vivien doesn’t know where they have taken
Sophia.
Brixil is now more strict with the vitamin
rule.
She feeds the girls the as vitamins herself.
That night, Vivien stabs herself with her
hair clip to try and stay awake.
She looks for the card everywhere on Sophia’s
bed, then finds it in the headboard of her own bed
Sophia had left it there to help her friend
run away.
Vivien tries to open the room door with it,
but it doesn’t work.
Then she gets an idea; she takes her hairpin
and starts to remove the door altogether.
She finally gets out of the room.
Then, she goes to Dr. Miro’s cabin and finds
Brixil there.
Brixil tries to inject Vivien with a sedative,
but she attacks her and injects her instead.
Vivien then asks her about Sophia’s whereabouts
but doesn’t get any answer.
She then sneaks into the prison cells in the
basement of the building.
Sophia is in one of the rooms there.
Using Brixil’s card, she manages to free
her.
But her hands are zip-tied.
The girls then find a surgical room with scissors.
They use it to cut the zip tie.
But they also reveal the body of their friend,
Rita.
She was taken that morning for punishment.
The girls are horrified to see her face has
been skinned; they are now determined to run away.
Sophia wants to warn other girls but Vivien
wants to run away, so they decide that Sophia
will go to the halls and bring all the girls
to a room, while Vivien stays there.
So, Sophia goes in and collects as many girls
as she can.
Meanwhile, as Vivien waits for her, she hears
a guard coming towards her.
She escapes and hides inside a room.
There, she finds a TV.
A video starts to play.
It is an advertisement of some sort.
Dr. Miro, in the video, explains a procedure
to regain your youth by planting a beautiful
donor’s face onto your own.
Vivien realizes that they have been brought
up all these years, and raised in a sterile
environment without sunlight, so rich "sponsors"
can pay to get the skin of these young girls
transplanted onto them, to make them appear
more youthful.
Rita’s face was skinned because she was
chosen by a client.
Elsewhere, Sophia brings all the girls to
a room.
She tries to explain to them what is happening
but the girls do not believe her.
They even threaten to call the guards.
But just then, Vivien comes in with Brixil.
She is intoxicated because of the sedative.
Vivien tells them about Rita’s skinned body
downstairs.
She then shows them Brixil’s scars revealing
that she too was a client, and was wearing
someone’s face.
The girls now finally believe them.
They take Brixil to the cell she had put Vivien
earlier in, and rush out of the building through
the escape door.
However, the guards find them midway.
Most of the girls run; but Sophia is caught
by the guard.
He injures her but the girls manage to push
him off the building, killing him.
Then, all of them run away in different directions.
The guards almost catch Sophia and Vivien,
but they lock themselves into an abandoned house.
Dr Miro and the guards are outside; and he
lovingly tells Vivien to come outside.
But Vivien cuts her face...proving that she
is of no use to Miro now.
The guards get a call from their boss who
orders them to kill Miro since he has failed.
That night, the girls stay in the room.
In the morning they are rescued by two police
officers.
The movie ends as Vivien and Sophia come outside
the house and see the rainfall for the first
time in their lives.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on notifications, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thank you for watching.